now unfortunately as case rates have
gone up we've needed to introduce more
of these local measures on Friday we
introduced new restrictions on household
mixing for Wigan Stockport Blackpool and
leads and today I must announce further
measures for the parts of the Northeast
where we introduced local action a
fortnight ago unfortunately the number
of cases continues to rise sharply the
incident rate across the area is now
over a 100 cases per 100,000 we know
that a large number of these infections
are taking place in indoor settings
outside the home and so at the request
of the local councils with whom we've
been working closely we will introduce
legal restrictions on indoor mixing
between households in any setting Mr
Speaker we do not take these steps
lightly but we must take them and take
them now because we know that Swift
action is more likely to bring the virus
under control and the quicker we can get
this virus under control control the
quicker we can restore the freedoms we
all enjoy in the Northeast and across
the country finally Mr Speaker all the
time that we've been fighting to
suppress the virus so too we've fought
to protect people the Furlow scheme the
bounceback loans funding for social care
for the Charities for the Arts
unprecedented support for the NHS so we
could protect the NHS through the peak
and now work through the backlog that
the peak inevitably caused through the
huge challenges is we secured the supply
lines for the vital PPE and hence we can
launch our PPE winter plan now and I'd
like to pay tribute to Lord dyon his
team and all the businesses who are
stepping up because their work has put
us in such strong stead to protect those
who are performing heroics on the front
line